We got some
fresh fish, fellas!
Welcome to my jail, son.
You're in here
cause they say you gotta pay.
I'm in here to
make sure you do.
Congratulations, Adams.
You are a father.
Nobody told you?
You’re going to spend the rest of your life in here.
You ain't never
going to see that-
(screams)
Truth is,
I never thought
about being a father.
He’s a little mama's boy.
You know,
you don't have to
be like him, right?
Look,
I just want to
be there for my kid.
If freedom’s a state of mind,
I guess my dreams
should be enough.
Just think about
how much better
your kid’s going to
be without you around.
Bosco, when are
you gonna grow up?
I ain't content with dreaming.
Humans are
the greatest weakness
in any security system.
Prisons aren’t inescapable,
they’re just meant
to feel that way.
Need your help.
I know the game bro.
You think reading is going to save your ass?
No, I do not, sir.
I’m straight G.
Have at it.
I am so close to
not only freedom,
but also being a real father.
I would like to help you.
I want that more than anything in the world.
(screams)
You can only protect yourself
by your choices.
Oh my gosh.